[MUSIC PLAYING]
MARTIN GORNER: Hello.
Hi, everyone.
So thank you for coming
in such great numbers
to this TensorFlow session.
Apologies, it's quite
late in the afternoon.
I will need all your brains
for this session because today,
I want with you to
build a neural network.
So no, I don't need your
brains to build on, no brain
surgery in the session.
But it's a crash course
to get developers up
to speed on machine learning
and deep learning and neural
networks.
So I need all your attention.
The dataset we will be using
is a very classical one.
It's this one here,
hand-written digits.
Academia has been working on
this dataset for the past 20
years.
So you should go to the
website where it's hosted.
You will actually see 20
years of research papers
and that's what we
will do together today.
We'll go on this dataset
trying to build a network that
recognizes this hand-written
digits from the simplest
possible network all
the way to 99% accuracy.
So let's start.
Just a question, beforehand.
Who has done some work with
neural networks before?
Oh, wow.
OK.
Quite a few people.
So feel free to help me
and I hope this will not
be too basic for
you and I hope it
will at least be a good
introduction to TensorFlow.
But if you have never done
anything with neural networks,
that's fine and I will explain
everything from the start.
So this is the simplest
possible neural network
we can imagine to recognize
our hand-written digits.
So the digits, they come
as 28 by 28 pixel images
and the first thing we
do is that we flatten
all those pixels into
one big vector of pixels
and these will be our inputs.
Now, we will use
exactly 10 neurons.
The neurons are
the white circles.
What a neuron does is
always the same thing.
A neuron does a weighted
sum of all of its inputs,
here the pixels.
It adds another constant
that is called a bias.
That's just an additional
degree of freedom.
And then it will feed this sum
through an activation function.
And that is just a function--
number in, transform,
number out.
We will see several of
those activation functions
and the one thing they have
in common in neural networks
is that they are non-linear.
So why 10 neurons?
Well, simply because we are
classifying those digits
in 10 categories.
We are trying to recognize
a zero, a one, a two,
on to the nine.
So what we are hoping for here
is that one of those neurons
will light up and tell us,
with a very strong output,
that I have recognized
here an eight.
All right.
And for that, since this is
a classification problem,
we are going to use a
very specific activation
function, one that,
well, researchers
tell us works really well
on classification problems.
It's called softmax
and it's simply
an exponential normalized.
So what you do is that you
make all those weighted sums,
then you elevate that
to the exponential.
And once you have
your 10 exponentials,
you compute the
norm of this vector
and divide it by its
norm so that you get
values between zero and one.
And those values, you will
be able to interpret them
as probabilities, probabilities
of this being an eight, a one,
or something else.
You will be asking which norm?
Any norm, doesn't matter--
the length of the vector.
You pick your favorite norm.
There are several.
Usually, for softmax,
we use L1, but L2
which is the Euclidean normal
would work just as well.
So what does
softmax do actually?
You see, it's an exponential so
it's a very steeply increasing
function.
It will pull the data apart,
increase the differences,
and when you divide all of
that, when you normalize
the whole vector, you usually
end up with one of the values
being very close to one
and all the other values
being very close to zero.
So it's a way of pulling
the winner out on top
without actually
destroying the information.
All right.
So now we need to formalize
this using a matrix multiply.
I will remind you of what
a matrix multiply is,
but we will do it
not one image, we
are going to do this for a
batch of 100 images at a time.
So what we have
here in my matrix
is 100 images, one
image per line.
The images are flattened,
all the pixels on one line.
So I take my matrix of
weights, for the time being,
I don't know what
these weights are,
it's just weights so
I'm doing weighted sums.
And I start the
matrix multiplication.
So I do a weighted sum of all
the pixels of the first image.
Here it is.
And then if I continue
this matrix multiply
using the second
column of weights,
I get a weighted sum
of all the pixels
of the first image for
the second neuron and then
for the third neuron and
the fourth and so on.
What is left is
to add the bias's,
just an additional constant.
Again, we don't know what
it is for the time being.
And there is one
bias per neuron,
that's why we have 10 biases.
And now if I continue
this matrix multiply,
I'm going to obtain
these weighted sums
for the second image,
and the third image,
and so on, until I have
processed all my images.
I would like to write this
as a simple formula there.
You see there is a
problem, x times w,
you know that's a matrix of
10 columns by 100 images,
and I have only 10 biases.
I can't simply
add them together.
Well, never mind.
We will redefine
addition and it's OK
if everybody accepts it.
And actually, people
have already accepted it.
It's called a broadcasting
add and that's
the way you do
additions in NumPy,
for instance, which is the
numerical library for Python.
The way a broadcasting
add works is
that if you're trying to add two
things which don't match, not
the same dimensions, you
can't do the addition,
you try to replicate
the small one as much
as needed to make
the sizes match
and then you do the addition.
That's exactly what
we need to do here.
We have only those 10 biases.
So it's the same biases
on all the lines.
We just need to replicate this
bias vector on all the lines,
and that's exactly what this
generalized broadcasting
add does.
So we will just
write it as a plus.
And this is where
I wanted to get to.
I want you to remember this
as the formula describing
one layer in a neural network.
So let's go through this again.
In x, we have a batch
of images, 100 images,
all the pixels on one line.
In w, we have all of our
weights for the 10 neurons,
all the weights in the system.
x times w are all
about weighted sums.
We add the biases,
and then we feed this
through our activation function,
in this case softmax, the way
it works is lined by line.
Line by line, we
take the 10 values,
elevate them to the
exponential, normalize the line.
Next line, 10 values, elevate
them to the exponential,
normalize the line, and so on.
So what we get in the output
is, for each image, 10 values
which look like probabilities
and which are our predictions.
So, of course, we
still don't know
what those weights
and biases are
and that's where the trick
is in neural networks.
We are going to train
this neural network
to actually figure out
the correct weights
and biases by itself.
Well, this is how we
write this in TensorFlow.
You see, not very different.
OK.
TensorFlow has this in n
library for neural network
which has all sorts of
very useful functions
for neural networks, for
example, softmax and so on.
So let's go train.
When you train,
you've got images,
but you know what
those images are.
So your network, you initialize
your weights and biases
at random value and your network
will output some probability.
Since you know
what this image is,
you can tell it that it's
not this, it should be that.
So that is called a
one-hot encoded vector.
It's a not very fancy
way of encoding numbers.
Basically, here are our
numbers from zero to nine.
We encode them as 10 bits, all
at zero and just one of them
is a one at the index of the
number we want to encode.
Here are six.
Why?
Well, because then, it's in the
same shape as our predictions
and we can compute a
distance between those two.
So again, many ways of
computing distances.
The Euclidean distance,
the normal distance, sum
of differences squared
would work, not a problem.
But scientists tell us that
for classification problems,
this distance, the cross
entropy, works slightly better.
So we'll use this one.
How does it work?
It's the sum across the
vectors of the values
on the top multiplied by
the logarithms of the values
on the bottom, and then
we add in minus sign
because all the values on
the bottom are less than one,
so all the logarithms
are negative.
So that's the distance.
And of course, we
will tell the system
to minimize the distance between
what it thinks is the truth
and what we know to be true.
So this we will call
our error function
and the training will
be guided by an effort
to minimize the error function.
So let's see how this
works in practice.
So in this little
visualization, I'm
showing you over there,
my training images.
You see it's training so you
see this batches of 100 training
images being fed
into the system.
On the white background,
you have the images
that have been already correctly
recognized by the system.
On a red background, images
that are still missed.
So then, on the
middle graph, you
see our error function, computed
both on the training dataset
and we also kept aside a set of
images which we have never seen
during training for testing.
Of course, if you want
to test the real world
performance of your
neural network,
you have to do this on a set
of images which you have never
seen during training.
So here we have
60,000 training images
and I set aside 10,000
test images which you see
in the bottom graph over there.
They are a bit small.
You see only 1,000 of them here.
So imagine, there are nine more
screens of pictures like that.
But I sorted all the badly
recognized one at the top.
So you see all the ones that
have been badly recognized
and below are nine screens of
correctly recognized images,
here after 2,000
rounds of training.
So there is a little
scale on the side here.
It shows you that it's
already capable of recognizing
92% of our images with this very
simple model, just 10 neuron's,
nothing else.
And that's what you get on the
top graph, the accuracy graph,
as well.
That's simply the percentage
of correctly recognized images,
both on test and training data.
So what else do we have?
We have our weights and biases,
those two diagrams are simply
percentiles, so it
shows you the spread
of all the weights and biases.
And that's just useful to
see that they are moving.
They both started at zero
and they took some values
for the weights between
one and minus one
for biasses between
two and minus two.
It's helpful to keep an
eye on those diagrams
and see that we are not
diverging completely.
So that's the
training algorithm.
You give it training images,
it gives you a prediction,
you compute the distance
between the prediction
and what you know to be true.
You use that
distance as an error
function to guide a mechanism
that will drive the error down
by modifying weights and biases.
So now let's write
this in TensorFlow.
And I'll get more
explicit about exactly how
this training works.
So we need to write
this in TensorFlow.
The first thing you
do in TensorFlow
is define variables
and placeholders.
A variable is a
degree of freedom
of our system, something we are
asking TensorFlow to compute
for us through training.
So in our case, those are
our weights and biases.
And we will need to
feed in training data.
So for this data that will
be fed in at training time,
we define a placeholder.
You see here x is a placeholder
for our training images.
Let's look at the
shape in brackets.
What you have is the shape of
this multidimensional matrix,
which we call a tensor.
So the first dimension is none.
It says I don't know yet so this
will be the number of images
in a batch.
This will be determined
at training time.
If we give 100 images,
this will be 100.
Then 28 by 28 is the
size of our images
and one is the number
of values per pixel.
So that's not useful
at all because we
are handling grayscale images.
I just put it there.
In case you wanted to handle
color images, that would
be three values per pixel.
So OK.
We have our placeholders,
we have our variables,
now we are ready
to write our model.
So that line you see on
the top is our model.
It's what we have determined
to be the line representing
one layer of a neural network.
The only change is
that reshape operation.
You remember, our images,
they come in as 28
by 28 pixel images and
we want to flatten them
as one big vector of pixels.
So that's what reshape does.
784 is 28 by 28.
It's all the pixels in one line.
All right.
I need a second placeholder
for the known answers,
the labels of my
training images,
labels like this is a one, this
is a zero, this is a seven,
this is a five.
And now that I have my
predictions and my known
labels, I'm ready to compute
my error function, which
is the cross entropy using
the formula we've seen before.
So the sum across the vector
of the elements of the labels
multiplied by elements of the
logarithm of the predictions.
So now I have my error function.
What do I do with it?
What you have on the bottom,
I won't go into that.
That is simply the
computation of the percentage
of correctly recognized images.
You can skip that.
OK.
Now we get to the
actual heart of what
TensorFlow will do for you.
So we have our error function.
We pick an optimizer.
There is a full library of them.
They have different
characteristics.
And we ask the optimizer to
minimize our error function.
So what is this going to do?
When you do this, TensorFlow
takes your error function
and computes the partial
derivatives of that error
function relatively to all
the weights and all the biases
in the system.
That's a big vector
because there are lots
of weights and lots of biases.
How many?
w, the weights, is a variable
of almost 8,000 values.
So this vector we
get mathematically
is called a gradient.
And the gradient has
one nice property.
Who knows what is the nice
property of the gradient?
It points-- Yeah.
Almost.
It points up, we had a minus
sign, it points down, exactly.
Down in which space?
We are in the space of all the
weight and all the variables
and the function
we are computing
is our error function.
So when we say
down in this space,
it means it gives us a direction
in the space of weights
and biases into which to
go to modify our weights
and biases in order to make
our error function smaller.
So that is the training.
You compute this gradient
and it gives you an arrow.
You take a little
step along this arrow.
Well, you are in the space
of weights and biases,
so taking a little step
means you modify your weights
and biases by this little delta,
and you get into a location
where the error is now smaller.
Well, that's fantastic.
That's exactly what you want.
Then you repeat this
using a second batch
of training images.
And again, using a third batch
of training images, and so on.
So it's called gradient
descent because you follow
the gradient to head down.
And so we are ready to
write our training loop.
There is one more
thing I need to explain
to you about TensorFlow.
TensorFlow has a
deferred execution model.
So everything we
wrote up to now,
all the tf dot
something here commands,
does not actually--
when that is executed,
it doesn't produce values.
It builds a graph, a
computation graph, in memory.
Why is that important?
Well, first of all, this
derivation trick here,
the computation of
the gradient, that
is actually a formal derivation.
TensorFlow takes
the formula that you
give it to define
your error function
and does a formal
derivation on it.
So it needs to know the full
graph of how you computed this
to do this formal derivation.
And the second thing it
will use this graph for
is that TensorFlow is built
for distributed computing.
And there, as well,
to distribute a graph
on multiple machine, it helps
to know what the graph is.
OK.
So this is all very
useful, but it means for us
that we have to go
through an additional loop
to actually get values
from our computations.
The way you do
this in TensorFlow
is that you define a session
and then in the session,
you call sess.run on one edge
of your computation graph.
That will give
you actual values,
but of course, for
this to work, you
have to fill in all
the placeholders
that you have defined
now with real values.
So for this to work, I will need
to fill in the training images
and the training
labels for which
I have defined placeholders.
And the syntax is simply the
train_data dictionary there.
You see the keys of the
dictionary, x and y underscore,
are the placeholders
that I have defined.
And then I can sess.run
on my training step.
I pass in this training
data and that is
where the actual magic happens.
Just a reminder, what
is this training step?
Well it's what you got when you
asked the optimizer to minimize
your error function.
So the training
step, when executed,
is actually what computes
this gradient using
the current batch of images,
training images and labels,
and follows it a little to
modify the weights and biases
and end up with better
weights and biases.
I said a little.
I come back to this.
What is that learning
rate over there?
Well, I can't make a big
step along the gradient.
Why not?
Imagine you're in the mountains,
you know where down is.
We have senses for that.
We don't know to
derive anything.
We know where down is.
And you want to reach
the bottom of the valley.
Now, if every step you
make is a 10 mile step,
you will probably be jumping
from one side of the valley
to the other without
ever reaching the bottom.
So if you want to
reach the bottom,
even if you know
where a down is,
you have to make small
steps in that direction,
and then you will
reach the bottom.
So the same here, when
we compute this gradient,
we multiplied by this very small
value so as to take small steps
and be sure that we not jumping
from one side of the valley
to the other.
All right.
So let's finish our training.
Basically, in a loop, we load
a batch of 100 training images
and labels.
We run this training step which
adjusts our weights and biases.
And we repeat.
All the rest of the stuff on the
bottom, it's just for display.
I'm computing the accuracy
and the cross entropy
on my training data and
again, on my test data
so that I can show you
four curves over there.
It is just for display.
It has nothing to do
with the training itself.
All right.
So that was it.
That's the entire code
here on one slide.
Let's go through this again.
At the beginning, you define
variables for everything
that you want TensorFlow
to compute for you.
So here are our
weights and biasses.
You define placeholders
for everything
that you will be feeding during
the training, namely our images
and our training labels.
Then you define your model.
Your model gives
you predictions.
You can compare
those predictions
with your known labels,
compare the distance
between the two, which is
the cross entropy here,
and use that as
an error function.
So you pick an optimizer and you
ask the optimizer to minimize
your error function.
That gives all the
gradients and all
that, it gives you
a training step.
And now, in a loop, you
load a batch of images.
You're on your training step.
You load a batch of
images and labels,
you run your training step,
and you do this in a loop,
and hoping this will
converge, and usually it does.
You see here, it did converge
and with this approach,
we got 92% accuracy.
Small recap of all the
ingredients we put in our pot
so far.
We have a softmax
activation function.
We have the cross entropy
as an error function.
And we did this
mini batching thing
where we train on 100 images
at a time, do one step,
and then load another
batch of images.
So is 92% accuracy good?
No, it's horrible.
Imagine you're actually
using this in production.
I don't know, in the post
office, your decoding zip
codes.
92% out of 100 digits,
you have eight bad values?
No, not usable in production.
Forget it.
So how do we fix it?
Well deep learning.
We'll go deep.
We can just stack those layers.
How do we do that?
Well, it's very simple.
Look at the top
layer of neurons.
It does what we just did.
It computes weighted
sums of pixels.
But we can just as
easily add a second layer
of neurons that will
compute weighted sums all
the outputs of the first layer.
And that's how you
stack layers to produce
a deep neural network.
Now we are going to change
our activation function.
We keep softmax for
the output layer
because softmax has
these nice properties
of pulling a winner
apart and producing
numbers between zero and one.
But for the rest, we use a very
classical activation function.
In neural networks,
it's called the sigmoid,
and it's basically, the simplest
possible continuous function
that goes from zero to one.
OK.
All right.
Let's write this model.
So we have now one set of
weights and one set of biasses
per layer.
That's why we use C5 pairs here.
And our model will actually
look very familiar to you.
Look at the first line.
It's exactly what we
have seen before for one
layer of a neural network.
Now what we do with
the output, Y1,
is that we use it as the
input in the second line,
and so on, we chain those.
It's just that on the
last line, the activation
function we use is the softmax.
So that's all the
changes we did.
And we can try to
run this again.
So oops.
This one.
Run.
And it's coming.
Well, I don't like
this slope here.
It shouldn't be shooting
up really sharp.
It's a bit slow.
Actually, I have a
solution for that.
I lied to you when I said that
the sigmoid was the most widely
used activation function.
That was true in the
past, and today, people
invented a new activation
function, which is called
the Relu, and this is a relu.
It's even simpler.
It's just zero for all
negative values and identity
for all positive values.
Now this actually works better.
It has lots of advantages.
Why does it work better?
We don't know.
People tried it,
it worked better.
[LAUGHTER]
I'm being honest here.
If you had a researcher
here, he would
fill your head with
equations and prove it,
but he would have done those
equations after the fact.
People already tried
it, it worked better.
Actually, they got
inspiration from biology.
It is said, I don't
know if it is true,
but I heard that the
sigmoid was the preferred
model of biologists for our
actual biological neurons
and that today, biologist
thinks that neurons in our head
work more like this.
And the guys in
computer science got
inspiration from that,
tried it, works better.
How better?
Well, this is just the
beginning of the training.
This is what we get with our
sigmoids, just 300 iterations,
so just the beginning.
And this is what
we get from relus.
Well, I prefer this.
The accuracy shoots
up really sharp.
The cross entropy goes
down really sharp.
It's much faster.
And actually, here on
this very simple problem,
the sigmoid would have
recovered, it's not an issue,
but in very deep networks,
sometimes with the sigmoid,
you don't converge at all.
And the relu solves that
problem to some extent.
So the relu it is for
most of our issues.
OK.
So now let's train.
Let's do this for 10,000
iterations, five layers,
look at that.
98% accuracy.
First of all, oh, yeah.
We went from 92 to 98
just by adding layers.
That's fantastic.
But look at those curves.
They're all messy.
What is all this noise?
Well, when you see
noise like that,
it means that you
are going too fast.
You're actually jumping
from one side of the valley
to the other, without
critically reaching the bottom
of your error function.
So we have a solution for
that, but it's not just
to go slower, because then you
would spend 10 times more time
training.
The solution, actually,
is to start fast and then
slow down as you train.
It's called learning rate decay.
We usually decay the learning
rates on an exponential curve.
So yes, I hear you.
It sounds very simple,
why this little
trick, but let me play you
the video of what this does.
It's actually quite spectacular.
So it's almost there.
Should I have the
end of it on a slide.
Yeah, that's it.
So this is what we had
using a fixed learning rate
and just by switching to a
decaying learning rate, look,
it's spectacular.
All the noise is gone.
And for the first--
just with this little trick--
really, this is
not rocket science,
it's just going slightly
slower towards the end
and all the noise is gone.
And look at the blue curve,
the training accuracy curve.
Towards the end,
it's stuck at 100%.
So here, for the first time,
we built a neural network
that was capable of learning all
of our training set perfectly.
It doesn't make one single
mistake in the entire training
set which doesn't mean that
it's perfect in the real world.
As you see on the test
dataset, it has a 98% accuracy.
But, well, it's something.
We got 100% at least
on the training.
All right.
So we still have something
that is a bit bizarre.
Look at those two curves.
This is our error function.
So the blue curve, the
test error function,
that is what we minimize.
OK?
So as expected, it goes down.
And the error function
computed on our test data
at the beginning,
well, it follows.
That's quite nice.
And then it disconnects.
So this is not completely
unexpected, you know.
We are minimizing the
training at our function.
That's what we are
actively minimizing.
We are not doing anything
at all on the test side.
It's just a byproduct of
the way neural networks work
that the training you do
on your training data,
actually carries over to your
test data to the real world.
Well, it carries
over or it doesn't.
So as you see here,
until some point,
it does and then,
there is a disconnect,
it doesn't carry over anymore.
You keep optimizing the
error on the training data,
but it has no positive
effect on the test
performance, the real
work performance, anymore.
So if you see curves like
this, you take the textbook,
you look it up, it's
called overfitting.
You look at the solutions,
they tell you overfitting,
you need regularization.
OK.
Let's regularize.
What regularization
options do we have?
My preferred one
is called dropout.
It's quite dramatic.
You shoot the neurons.
No, really.
So this is how it works.
You take your neural network,
and pick a probability,
let's say 50%.
So at each training
iteration, you
will shoot, physically
remove from the network,
50% percent of your neurons.
Do the pass, then put them back,
next iteration, again, randomly
shoot 50% of your neurons.
Of course, when you test , you
don't test with a half brain
dead neural network, you
put all the neurons back.
But that's what you
do for training.
So in TensorFlow, there
is a very simple function
to do that, which is called
dropout, That you apply
at the outputs of the layer.
And what it simply does is
it takes the probability
and in the output
of that layer, it
will replace randomly
some values by zeros
and small technicality,
it will actually
boost the remaining
values proportionally
so that the average
stays constant,
that's a technicality.
So why does shooting
neurons help?
Well, first of all,
let's see if it helps.
So let's try to recap all
the tricks we tried to play
with our neural network.
This is what we had initially
with our five layers
using the sigmoid as
an activation function.
The accuracy got up to
97.9% using five layers.
So first, we replaced the
sigmoid by the relu activation
function.
You see, it's faster to
converge at the beginning
and we actually gained
a couple of fractions
of percentage of accuracy.
But we have these messy curves.
So we train slower using the
exponential learning rate decay
and we get rid of the noise, and
now we are stable or above 98%
accuracy.
But we have that
weird disconnect
between the error
on our test data
and the error on
our training data.
So let us try to add dropout.
This is what you
get with dropout.
And actually, the
cross entropy function,
the test cross entropy
function, the red one
over there on the right,
has been largely brought
under control.
You see, there is
still some disconnect,
but it's not shooting
up as it was before.
That's very positive.
Let's look at the accuracy.
No improvement.
Actually, I'm even amazed
that it hasn't gone down
seeing how brutal this
technique is, you shoot neurons
while you train.
But here, I was very
hopeful to get it up.
No, nothing.
We have to keep digging.
So what is really overfitting?
Let's go beyond the simple
recipe in the textbook.
Overfitting, in
a neural network,
is primarily when you give it
too many degrees of freedom.
Imagine you have so
many neurons and so many
weights in a neural
network that it's somehow
feasible to simply store
all the training images
in those weights and variables.
You have enough room for that.
And the neural network could
figure out some cheap trick
to pattern match the training
images in what it has stored
and just perfectly recognize
your training images
because it has stored
copies of all of them.
Well, if it has enough
space to do that,
that would not translate to any
kind of recognition performance
in the real world.
And that's the trick
about neural networks.
You have to constrain
their degrees of freedom
to force them to generalize.
And mostly, when
you get overfitting
is because you have
too many neurons.
You need to get that number
down to force the network
to produce generalizations
that will then
produce good predictions,
even in the real world.
So either you get the
number of neurons down
or you apply some
trick, like dropout,
that is supposed to mitigate
the consequences of too
many degrees of freedom.
The opposite of too many
neurons if you have a very small
dataset, well, even if you have
only a small number of neurons,
if the dataset, the training
dataset is very small,
it can still fit it all in.
So that's a general
truth in neural networks.
You need big datasets
for training.
And then what happened here?
We have a big data set,
60,000 digits, that's enough.
We know that we don't have too
many neurons because we added
five layers, that's a bit
overkill, but I tried,
I promise, with four
and three and two.
And we tried dropout
which is supposed
to mitigate the fact that
you have too many neurons.
And it didn't do
anything to the accuracy.
So the conclusion
here that we come to
is that our network, the way
it is built, is inadequate.
It's not capable
by its architecture
to extract the necessary
information from our data.
And maybe someone here can
pinpoint something really
stupid we did at the beginning.
Someone has an idea?
Remember, we have images?
Images with shapes
like curves and lines.
And we flattened all the
pixels in one big vector.
So all that shape
information is lost.
This is terrible.
That's why we are
performing so badly.
We lost all of the
shape information.
So what is the solution?
Well, people have
invented a different type
of neural networks to
handle specifically
images and problems
where shape is important.
It's called
convolutional networks.
Here we go back to the
general case of an image,
of a color image.
So that's why it has red,
green, and blue components.
And in a convolutional
network, one neuron
will still be doing
weighted sums of pixels,
but only a small patch of
pixels above its head, only
a small patch.
And the next neuron
would, again,
be doing weighted sum of
the small patch of pixels
above itself, but
using the same weights.
OK?
That's the
fundamental difference
from what we have seen before.
The second neuron is
using the same weights
as the first neuron.
So we are actually taking
just one set of weights
and we are scanning the
image in both directions,
using that set of weights
and producing weighted sums.
So we scan it in both
directions and we obtain
one layer of weighted sums.
So how many weights do we have?
Well, as many weights
as we have input values
in that little highlighted
cube, that's 4 times 4 times
3, which is around 48.
What?
48?
We had 8,000 degrees of
freedom in our simplest network
with just 10 neurons.
How can it work with
such a drastic reduction
in the number of weights?
Well, it won't work.
We need more degrees of freedom.
How do we do that?
Well, we pick a second set
of weights and do this again.
And we obtain the second--
let's call it a channel of
values using different weights.
Now since those are
multi-dimensional matrices,
it's fairly easy to write
those two matrices as one
by simply adding a
dimension of dimension two
because we have
two sets of values.
And this here will be the
shape of the weight made matrix
for one convolutional
layer in a neural network.
Now, we still have
one problem left
which is that we need to bring
the amount of information down.
At the end, we still
want only 10 outputs
with our 10 probabilities to
recognize what this number is.
So traditionally, this
was achieved by what
we call a subsampling layer.
I think it's quite
useful to understand
how this works because it gives
you a good feeling for what
this network is doing.
So basically, we were
scanning the image using
a set of weights and during
training, these weights
will actually specialize in
some kind of shape recognizer.
There will be some
weights that will become
very sensitive to
horizontal lines
and some weights
that will become
very sensitive to
vertical lines, and so on.
So basically, when you scan
the image, if you simplify,
you get an output which is
mostly I've seen nothing,
I've seen nothing,
oh, I've seen something,
I've seen nothing, oh,
I've seen something.
The subsampling basically takes
four of those outputs, two
by two, and it takes
the maximum value.
So it retains the biggest
signal of I've seen something
and passes that down
to the layer below.
But actually, there's
a much simpler way
of condensing information.
What if we simply play with
the stride of the convolution?
Instead of scanning the
image pixel by pixel,
we scan it every two pixels,
we jumped by two pixels
between each weighted sum.
Well, mechanically,
instead of obtaining 28
by 28 output values, we obtain
only 14 by 14 output values.
So we have condensed
our information.
And mostly today, I'm not
saying this is better,
but it's just simpler.
And mostly today, people who
build convolutional networks
just use convolutional
layers and play
with the step to condense the
information and it's simpler.
You don't need, in this way, to
have these subsampling layers.
So this is the network that I
would like to build with you.
Let's go through it.
There is a first convolutional
layer that uses patches of five
by five.
I'm reading through
the W1 tensor.
And we have seen
that in this shape,
the two first digits is the
size of the patch you pass.
The third digits is
the number of channels
it's reading from the input.
So here I'm back
to my real example.
This is a grayscale image.
It has one value per pixel.
So I'm reading one
channel of information.
And I will be applying four
of those patches to my image.
So I obtain four channels
of output values.
OK?
Now second convolutional later,
this time, my stride is two.
So here, my outputs become
plains of 14 by 14 values.
So let's go through it.
I'm applying patches
of four by four.
I'm reading in four
channels of values
because that's why I
output in the first layer.
And this time, I will be
using eight different batches,
so I will actually produce
eight different channels
of weighted sums.
Nextly, again, a stride of two.
That's why I'm getting down
from 14 by 14 to seven by seven.
Batch is of four
by four, reading
in eight channels of
values because that's
what I had in the
previous layer,
and outputting 12
channels of values
this time because I used
12 different batches.
And now I apply a
fully connected layer.
So the kind of layer
we've seen before.
OK?
This fully connected layer,
I remember the differences
in this one, each neuron
does a weighted sum
of all the values in the
little cube of values above,
not just a batch,
all the values.
In the next neuron in the
fully connected network does,
again, a weighted sum of all the
values using its own weights.
It's not sharing weights.
That's the normal neural network
layer as we have seen before.
And finally, I apply my softmax
layer with my 10 outputs.
All right.
So can we write
this in TensorFlow?
Well, we need one set of weights
and biases for each layer.
The only difference is that
for the convolutional layers,
our weights will have
this specific shape
that we have seen before.
So choose numbers
for the filter size,
one number for the
number of input channels,
and one number for
the number of batches
which corresponds to the
number of output channels
that you produce.
For our normal layers, we
have the weights and bias as
defined as before.
And so you see this truncated
normal thingy up there?
That's just random.
OK?
Its a complicated
way of saying random.
So we initialize those weights
to random values, initially.
And now this is what our
model will look like.
So TensorFlow has these
helpful conv2d function.
If you give it the weights'
matrix and a batch of images,
it will scan them
in both directions.
Its just a double loop to scan
the image in both directions
and produce the weighted sums.
So we do those weighted sums.
We had a bias .
We feed this through
an activation function,
in this case, the relu,
and that's our outputs.
And again, the way of
stacking these layers
is to feed why one,
the first output,
has the input of the next layer.
All right.
After our three
convolutional layers,
we need to do a
weighted sum this time
of all the values in this seven
by seven by 12 little cube.
So to achieve that, we
will flatten this cube
as one big vector of values.
That's what the
Reshape here does.
And then, two additional lines
that you should recognize,
those are normal neural network
layers as we have seen before.
All right.
How does this work?
So this time, it takes
a little bit more time
to process so I have a video.
You see the accuracy's
shooting up really fast.
I will have to zoom.
And the promise to 99% accuracy
is actually not too far.
We're getting there.
Are we getting there?
We're not getting there.
Oh, damn.
I'm so disappointed again.
I really wanted to bring
this to 99% accuracy.
We'll have to do
something more, 98.9.
Dammit, that was so close.
All right.
Yes.
Exactly.
This should be your WTF moment.
What is that?
On the cross entropy loss curve.
OK, let me zoom on it.
You see that?
That disconnect?
Do we have a solution for this?
Dropout.
Yes.
Let's go shooting our neurons.
It didn't work last time,
maybe this time it will.
So actually, what we will do
here, it's a little trick.
It's almost a
methodology for coming up
with the ideal neural network
for a given situation.
And what I like doing is to
restrict the degrees of freedom
until it's apparent
that it's not optimal.
It's hurting the performance.
Here, I know that I
can get about 99%.
So I erased a
little bit too much.
And from that point, I give
it a little bit more freedom
and apply dropout to make sure
that this additional freedom
will not result in overfitting.
And that's basically
how you obtain
a pretty optimal neural
network for a given problem.
So that's what I have done here.
You see, the batches are a
slightly bigger, six, six,
five, five, four,
four, instead of five,
five, four, four, and so on.
And I've used a
lot more batches.
So six patches in the first
layer, 12 in the second layer,
and 24 in the third layer,
instead of four, eight, and 12.
And, I applied dropout in
the fully connected layer.
So why not in the other layers?
I tried both, it's
possible to apply dropout
in convolutional layers.
But actually, if you count
the number of neurons,
there is a lot more neurons
in the fully connected layer.
So it's a lot more efficient
to be shooting them there.
I mean, it hurts a
little bit too much
to shoot neurons where you
have only a few of them.
So with this, let's
run this again.
So again, the accuracy
shoots up very fast.
I will have to zoom in.
Look where the 99%
is and we are above!
Yes!
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you.
I promised you will get
above 99 and we are actually
quite comfortably above.
We get to 99.3%.
In this time, let's see what
our dropout actually did.
So this is what we had
with a five layer network
and already a little
more degrees of freedom.
So more patches in each layer.
You see, we are
already above 99%.
But we have this big
disconnect between the test
and the training cross entropy.
Letters apply dropout, boom.
The test cross entropy function
is brought in under control.
It's not shooting up as much.
And look, this time,
we actually had
a problem and this fixed it.
With just applying dropout,
we got 2/10 of a percent
more accuracy.
And here, we are fighting
for the last percent,
between 99 and 100.
So getting 2/10 is enormous
with just a little trick.
All right.
So there we have it.
We built this network and
brought it all the way
to 99% accuracy.
The Cliff's Notes
is just a summary.
And to finish, so this was
mostly about TensorFlow.
We also have a couple of
pre-trained APIs, which
you can use just as APIs if
your problem is standard enough
to fit into one of those Cloud
Vision, Cloud Speech, Natural
Language, or Translate APIs.
And if you want to run your
TensorFlow jobs in the cloud,
we also have this
Cloud ML Engine service
that allows you to
execute your TensorFlow
jobs in the cloud for training.
And what is even more
important, with just the click
of a button, you can
take a train model
and push it to
production behind an API
and start serving predictions
from the model in the cloud.
So I think that's a
little technical detail,
but from an engineering
perspective,
it's quite significant that you
have a very easy way of pushing
something to prod.
Thank you.
You have the code on GitHub
and this slide deck is freely
available at that URL.
And with that, we have
five minutes for questions,
if you have any.
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you.
[MUSIC PLAYING]